Now, so far we have only looked at a specific index
within an image matrix and done all kinds of mathematical operations,
point processes of doing, for example, additions of this one to another one.
So in essence in this one by looking at the index 0 1 2 and 0 1 2.
I'm just looking at this specific pixel and looking at the intensity of that.
What I want to now introduce in this lecture is that we
can actually expand this.
Not just looking at the one pixel but it's neighborhood.
So here, for example now, is a three by three neighborhood around this pixel.
We can look one, in all directions around this central pixel.
And basically, now we have a small sub-matrix which is
a three by three sub-matrix.
So how do we actually now start using information, not just at that point but
around that specific point.
So the question now we're interested in is, how do we smooth the signal?
Again, an image is represented as a matrix with
basically the intensity signals now inputted into each and
every, element, which now I can transverse by looking at the indices i and j.
Now we're interested in saying okay,
I'm going to take this three by three neighborhood and
smooth out the value here with respect to what's happening around it.
To help explain this, let's take this simple example of a 1D Signal.
This is the original 1D Signal and as we traverse through it,
you basically see simplify this, to be one of the rows off a image.
And these are my intensities.
And that's just for simplification just we'll take this as a 1D signal for now.
Our interest in is that I want to be now able to get rid of some of
the noise in this signal.
Here I'm showing you a smooth version of the signal.
Basically what I've done is now in essence run a process which
basically looks at different aspects of this image or
this signal here and says well this is too low.
I need to move this up a little bit based on how I can smooth this curve or
this whole image that would actually be represented here.
Making assumptions like sometimes I want to do this smoothing because this
might be an error or actually just want to smooth the signal out.
One of the best ways of doing a simple smoothing of a signal could be that
we can actually just take the average of the neighboring values.
So I could for example look at these four si, four image values and
intensity values and figure out the average of four or
five of them and replace it in the middle.
So here I'm showing a simple example how would I, I,
I would go about doing an average.
So this would be a moving average, what I'd take is I would take five values and
basically, sum them and then divide them by five to get the average of the five,
and replace, this element to have that value.
And I would do this by moving one by one, as I would go down these indices.
Another option would be is not just to do a one by one but actually, or
just not doing a summation of equal things but change the weights around.
Here is an example of that instance where now I give more weight to the one,
the value that I'm actually changing.
And less weight to the ones in the neighborhood.
So in this instance, I have a flat signal that I'm actually also averaging,
equally giving all neighborhood values equal weight.
And this one, I'm actually giving it a little bit of a ram.
And of course to sum this back and normalize it.
And this one, I had five of them.
I divided by five.
And here the sum is 16, so I divide by 16 to
be able to normalize the instance back to, the neighborhood that it's in.
And this allows me to do smoothing in different ways and again, these are moving
averages, and move from one pixel to the other, and start doing this.
And again, I'm showing this in a simple 1D example.